It's peak pollination season and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢里忙得不可开交，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. For many women, being a daughter is not just a family role. It's a lifelong job. From coordinating family holiday schedules to mediating arguments, a, quote, good daughter, unquote, is often expected to act as the glue that binds a family together. Today we're going to talk to a researcher who studies what she calls daughtering about the work of being a daughter. Why is this labor so often invisible to families and to women themselves? How does daughtering affect women's mental health and identity?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。对于许多女性来说，身为女儿不仅仅是一个家庭角色，更是一份终身的工作。从协调家庭节假日安排到调解争端，所谓的“好女儿”往往被期望成为维系家庭的粘合剂。今天，我们将采访一位研究她所谓“女儿工作”（daughtering）的研究人员，探讨身为女儿的职责。为什么这种劳动对家庭乃至女性自身来说往往是隐形的？“女儿工作”如何影响女性的心理健康和自我认同？
How does it change over the lifespan, from childhood to middle age? What role does birth order play is eldest daughter syndrome a real thing? And how can daughters and families rethink these roles to make them sustainable and fulfilling for everyone? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Allison Alford, a clinical associate professor at the Bailey University Hankemer School of Business. She holds a PhD in communication studies with a concentration in interpersonal communication
它在从童年到中年的整个生命周期中是如何变化的？出生顺序起什么作用？“长女综合征”是真实存在的吗？女儿和家庭如何重新思考这些角色，使之对每个人来说都可持续且令人满足？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是贝勒大学汉克默商学院的临床副教授艾莉森·阿尔福德博士。她拥有传播学博士学位，专注于人际传播。
from the University of Texas at Austin. Dr. Alford's research focuses on women, adult daughtering, work family balance, and invisible labor. She is author of the new book, Good Daughtering, the work you've always done, the credit you've never gotten and how to finally feel like enough. Dr. Alfred, thanks for joining me today. Thanks for having me, Kim. Great to be here. Let's start by talking about the word daughtering. I understand this is a term you coined. What does it mean and why do you think it was needed? Well, I should definitely say that the word daughtering itself predates me, but I am the first to use it
她毕业于德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校。阿尔福德博士的研究重点是女性、成年后的“女儿工作”、工作与家庭的平衡以及隐形劳动。她是新书《好女儿工作：你一直付出的劳动，你从未得到的认可，以及如何最终感到满足》的作者。阿尔福德博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。谢谢你的邀请，金。很高兴来到这里。让我们从“女儿工作”（daughtering）这个词开始谈起。据我了解，这是你创造的一个术语。它是什么意思？你为什么认为有必要提出这个词？嗯，我必须说明，“daughtering”这个词本身在我之前就存在了，但我可能是第一个以这种方式使用它的人。
in this particular way. So I want to make sure to say that because there's a really great book from the 70s, some researchers I think in Norway who talk about mothering and daughtering, but in a very different way. And so I
所以我一定要说明这一点，因为 70 年代有一本非常棒的书，我想是挪威的一些研究人员谈到了“母亲工作”（mothering）和“女儿工作”（daughtering），但方式非常不同。所以，我
started using the word daughtering because I thought it was important that we think about how adult daughters actively show up in families. And there are so many roles in our social world that we acknowledge have really, we have to take active part in if we want them to go well. If we want to be a good friend, we have to actively work towards
开始使用“daughtering”这个词，是因为我认为思考成年女儿如何在家庭中积极表现非常重要。在我们的社会世界中，有很多角色我们承认，如果我们希望它们顺利进行，就必须积极参与。如果我们想成为一个好朋友，我们就必须积极努力去
being a friend. But we have some active terms for that, you know, making friends, friendship, etc. With our partners, our romantic partners, we know it takes work to be a spouse, to be a wife, be a husband. And particularly, we are aware that mothers and mothering takes a lot of work and a lot of effort. But as I was researching this over 10 years ago and looking for somebody, anybody, who talked about the ways that daughters are important or essential for family life to stay connected and how women are actively showing up in their families, I couldn't find anything. And that's why I felt like daughtering was an important word to bring forward, not just because I'm claiming I discovered something brand new, but because I want to hear from everybody, how do we use it,
维系友谊。但我们有一些主动的词汇来描述这一点，比如交朋友、友谊等等。对于伴侣，我们的浪漫伴侣，我们知道成为配偶、妻子或丈夫需要付出努力。特别是，我们意识到母亲和“母亲工作”需要大量的劳动和努力。但当我在十多年前研究这个问题时，寻找任何谈论女儿如何对家庭生活保持联系至关重要，以及女性如何积极在家庭中表现的人时，我什么也没找到。这就是为什么我觉得“daughtering”是一个重要的词，不仅是因为我声称我发现了什么全新的东西，而是因为我想听听大家的意见，我们如何使用它，
how is it showing up in your life? And if we had more language like this, what could change in our social world? What does the work of daughtering entail? Is it physical, mental, emotional work, all of the above. In other words, what are the key aspects of daughtering? And what are some real-life examples of daughtering? One of the easiest ways to think about doing daughtering is that task way, instrumental labor. And a lot of people, when you talk about doing daughtering, their first concept goes to how women show up for their parents when their parents are elderly. So they drive them to the doctor or they come check on them or bring them a meal or get their prescriptions for them. So task labor and with elder parents, that's this obvious connection to understanding
它在你的生活中是如何体现的？如果我们有更多这样的语言，我们的社会世界会发生什么变化？“女儿工作”包含什么？是体力、脑力、情感劳动，还是以上皆有？换句话说，“女儿工作”的关键方面是什么？有哪些现实生活中的例子？思考“女儿工作”最简单的方法之一就是任务层面，即工具性劳动。当谈到“女儿工作”时，很多人的第一反应是女性在父母年迈时如何照顾他们。比如开车送他们去看医生，或者去探望他们，给他们带饭，或者帮他们取处方药。所以任务劳动，对于年迈的父母来说，这与理解
daughtering. And it's a good one, but it is a limited view of what daughtering is. Because daughters are doing the work of daughtering across their lifespan. My research focuses on what adult daughters do with independence and agency. So some of the work is. task work or doing work. That might be doing the work of setting up a visit, making a phone call, giving a gift, or I've had women in my research say, my parents' house was about to be hit by a tornado, so I went over there and boarded up the windows. Or their washing machine went out and they had to be at work, but I'm going to stay at home mom, so I went over there and met the worker. So some of these, some of the work of daughtering is tasks. So I call that do.
“女儿工作”有明显的联系。这是一个很好的切入点，但对“女儿工作”的看法有限。因为女儿在整个生命周期中都在进行“女儿工作”。我的研究重点是成年女儿如何运用独立性和自主权。所以有些工作是任务性的或执行性的。这可能包括安排探访、打个电话、送份礼物，或者我研究中的女性曾说，父母的房子快要被龙卷风袭击了，所以我过去把窗户钉上了。或者他们的洗衣机坏了，他们必须上班，但我是一个全职妈妈，所以我过去接待维修工人。所以，“女儿工作”中的一些工作是任务性的。我称之为“执行工作”。
doing work. There's also the feeling work, thinking work, and being work of daughtering. So that would include the emotional, the cognitive, and the identity work of daughtering. Emotional work includes soothing over disagreements, preventing or fixing conflict, whether between you and your parent or even between your parent and other people in the family. And thinking work is things like, planning, preparing, worrying, and having the space today in your life, even for something that might occur years or decades in the future. And the last kind of work that I like to talk about, and I think is the least obvious, is the identity work of being a daughter thinking, who am I representing this family? How do I want to continue the legacy,
“女儿工作”还包括感受工作、思考工作和存在工作。这包括“女儿工作”中的情感、认知和身份认同工作。情感工作包括平息分歧、预防或解决冲突，无论是你和父母之间，还是父母与家庭中其他人之间。思考工作是指规划、准备、担忧，以及在生活中为未来几年甚至几十年可能发生的事情留出空间。我想谈的最后一种工作，也是我认为最不明显的一种，是身为女儿的身份认同工作，思考：我代表这个家庭是谁？我如何延续母亲或父亲或我们家族姓氏的遗产？
of my mom or my dad or our family name. How do I want to keep traditions going, special meals, or places that we go? And how do I represent my parents or my family as a daughter, even when nobody else is around and I'm not actually interacting with someone? So as you can imagine, with doing, being, feeling, and thinking, only the doing is visible. And the other ones are invisible. And of course, even the doing one can be swept under the rug is unimportant. So a lot of the work of daughtering is hidden or unacknowledged. And that's sort of the critical piece of where women need a little bit of help and a little bit of, you know, permission to do something about that.
我如何保持传统、特别的餐点或我们去过的地方？即使在没有人在场、我没有与任何人互动时，我作为女儿如何代表我的父母或家庭？正如你所想象的，在执行、存在、感受和思考这四种工作中，只有执行是可见的。其他的都是隐形的。当然，即使是执行工作也可能被掩盖为不重要。所以，“女儿工作”的很多部分是隐藏的或未被承认的。这就是女性需要一点帮助和一点许可来对此采取行动的关键所在。
These sound like a lot of expectations, and I'm just wondering where they come from. Does it come from an individual family or is it coming from society more broadly? Yes, it is. You know, in communication studies, particularly we're interested in how meaning is made by communicating, communicating with our friends, our family, or the messages we get through our social system. So learning how to do daughtering and learning what daughters should do or what a good daughter is is often coming to us from messages very early in our life. Even when we're a small child, we're looking at our siblings, we're looking at our parent and how they're daughtering
这些听起来像是很多期望，我想知道它们来自哪里。是来自个人家庭，还是来自更广泛的社会？是的，确实如此。在传播学中，我们特别感兴趣的是通过交流——与朋友、家人交流，或者通过社会系统接收到的信息——来构建意义。所以，学习如何进行“女儿工作”，学习女儿应该做什么，或者什么是好女儿，往往很早就从我们生活中的信息中传达给我们。即使我们还是个小孩子，我们也在观察兄弟姐妹，观察父母如何对他们的父母进行“女儿工作”，
their parent or even multiple generations into the grandparents. And so we're learning by watching our family members, typically at least so far, these messages about how to be a good daughter are not explicitly given or trained to children, but rather absorbed or notice or implicit messages. But we also learn these things through media, watching TV shows when we see this idyllic relationship or we see a toxic relationship between a daughter and a parent. And we think, okay, that's clear that there's a moral message here of what not to do. And we learn a lot from our peers. And our peers, that's what I call the daughterhood.
甚至观察祖父母那几代人。所以我们通过观察家庭成员来学习。通常，至少到目前为止，这些关于如何成为好女儿的信息并不是明确给予或训练给孩子的，而是通过吸收、注意或隐性信息获得的。但我们也通过媒体学习这些东西，看电视节目时，当我们看到这种田园诗般的关系，或者看到女儿和父母之间有毒的关系时，我们想，好吧，这里有一个关于不该做什么的道德信息。我们从同龄人那里学到了很多。而我们的同龄人，就是我所说的“女儿群体”。
But then, of course, our individual families also determine what we want to do. How much agency does an actual daughter have? I'm just wondering because these are a lot of pressures that get put on women, whether it's explicit or implicit. And I'm just thinking, you know, when does it reach a point where you have to say, I can't do this? You know, you're asking too much of me. That seems to be a big part of the cultural conversation that we're having right now,
但当然，我们的个人家庭也决定了我们想做什么。一个真正的女儿有多少自主权？我只是想知道，因为这些是施加在女性身上的巨大压力，无论是显性的还是隐性的。我在想，什么时候会达到一个必须说“我做不到”的地步？你知道，你对我要求太多了。这似乎是我们现在正在进行的文化对话中的一个重要部分，
is that women are sitting up and noticing, wow, a lot is being expected of me. I don't know why or where this came from or why everybody wants me to do all these things, but my sibling doesn't have to do that or, you know, the daughter has to do that, but the son doesn't have to do that. And I think that there is more agency as we discover first what the problem is. So for a long time, we've been lingering or laboring under this problematic daughtering expectation and the invisibility, the lack of language, the lack of shared communication about our lived experience. And that has left us feeling really alone and impotent to do anything about it. But as we're starting to talk to each other, as daughters are talking about their experience and saying,
即女性正在坐下来注意到，哇，人们对我期望很高。我不知道为什么，也不知道这来自哪里，或者为什么每个人都想让我做所有这些事情，但我的兄弟姐妹不需要这样做，或者，你知道，女儿必须这样做，但儿子却不需要。我认为，当我们首先发现问题所在时，自主权就会增加。所以很长一段时间以来，我们一直徘徊或劳累在这种有问题的“女儿工作”期望和隐形状态下，缺乏语言，缺乏关于我们生活经验的共同交流。这让我们感到非常孤独，无力做任何事情。但当我们开始互相交谈，当女儿们谈论她们的经历并说，
I don't like this or why is this happening in this world that these people are expecting this? More and more are agency blossoms where we can, we notice the problem and identify it and describe, what the well-being or burnout issue is, then we have the opportunity to say, I want to make changes. And I think that's the essence of the book that I have coming out. Or maybe by the time listeners are hearing this, it's already out, the book called Good Daughering. The first part of the book is like, hey, what is daughtering? You are doing a lot. You probably didn't even notice.
我不喜欢这样，或者为什么在这个世界上人们期望这些？随着我们注意到问题并描述幸福感或倦怠问题，我们的自主权就会萌芽，然后我们就有机会说，我想做出改变。我认为这就是我即将出版的书的核心。或者也许当听众听到这个节目时，这本书已经出版了，书名是《好女儿工作》。书的第一部分是，嘿，什么是“女儿工作”？你做了很多。你可能甚至没有注意到。
But once you start to look at it and list it off and have someone tell you, these are all the things daughters do. And you're doing 75% of them. You realize, oh, my gosh, I am doing daughtering. I am showing up. And so I don't have to have this reason of constantly feeling not good enough or like I'm not enough of a daughter or need to do more. And then the second part of the book is an investigation of, okay, what does? do I want in my life? What do I like? What does my family actually need versus what I was just presuming they need without asking anyone? Or presuming I had to do because I'm keeping up with the neighbor or the
但一旦你开始审视它，列出它，并让别人告诉你，这些都是女儿做的事情。而你做了其中的 75%。你意识到，天哪，我确实在进行“女儿工作”。我确实在付出。所以我不需要一直感到不够好，或者觉得我作为一个女儿做得不够，或者需要做得更多。然后书的第二部分是对以下问题的调查：好吧，我的生活中想要什么？我喜欢什么？我的家人真正需要什么，而不是我没有问任何人就假设他们需要什么？或者假设我必须做，因为我在跟邻居或
peer who seems to be doing these things. And the third part of the book is, okay, I've decided what I want and what I kind of would like some shifts I would want. How do I do that? How do I have these conversations with my family, with my siblings, with my partner, how do I set boundaries and how do I enjoy being a daughter and love my family without this specter of constant pain, burnout, and sadness, disillusionment that really can persist if we don't burst through it and talk about it and decide how do I want to handle this as an agent of change for my life and in my family. I want to ask about
同龄人攀比，而他们似乎在做这些事情。书的第三部分是，好吧，我已经决定了我想要什么，以及我想要的一些转变。我该怎么做？我如何与家人、兄弟姐妹、伴侣进行这些对话，我如何设定界限，以及我如何享受身为女儿的快乐并爱我的家人，而没有那种持续的痛苦、倦怠、悲伤和幻灭的阴影？如果我们不突破它，谈论它，并决定我作为自己生活的变革者想要如何处理这个问题，这种阴影真的会持续存在。我想问一下
sibling order and family size. I've read media articles about what some people call eldest daughter syndrome. Is this a real thing? Do the eldest or, depending on how many kids are elder daughters, tend to take on more daughtering responsibilities
兄弟姐妹顺序和家庭规模。我读过关于一些人所说的“长女综合征”的媒体文章。这是真实存在的吗？长女，或者取决于有多少孩子，长女是否倾向于承担更多的“女儿工作”责任
than their other siblings? Well, it's such a unique and interesting phenomenon that's going on. with the eldest daughter syndrome, and I am so impressed and love the stories of women who have been talking for the past few years about their experience of daughtering in their families. So the first question is, is eldest daughter syndrome real? Well, if the women say it's real, I believe it's real. The second question, is it a predictive diagnostic tool that we might
比其他兄弟姐妹多？嗯，这是一个非常独特且有趣的现象，关于“长女综合征”，我对过去几年一直在谈论她们在家庭中进行“女儿工作”经历的女性的故事印象深刻，也非常喜欢。所以第一个问题是，“长女综合征”是真实的吗？嗯，如果女性说它是真实的，我相信它是真实的。第二个问题，它是一个预测性的诊断工具吗？我们可能会
use or put in the DSM-5 or something like that? And as of yet, no, it's not a birth order is not actually predictive of who might do what. And what all that means is to say that I think when an eldest daughter says, I'm experiencing this, this is real in my life, I believe her, and I can learn a lot from her lived experience and what she's saying. That isn't, however, what the research shows is universally true. Typically, what we see with who does the most caregiving. And again, this is research related to more elderhood, illness, things like that. The child who does the most is the geographically closest child. And the second indicator would be the most economically available child, the one who has the finances to help, meaning that they
使用它或把它放进 DSM-5（精神疾病诊断与统计手册）之类的东西里吗？目前还没有，出生顺序实际上并不能预测谁可能会做什么。所有这些意味着，我认为当一个长女说，我正在经历这个，这在我的生活中是真实的，我相信她，我可以从她的生活经历和她所说的话中学到很多。然而，研究表明这并非普遍正确。通常，我们看到谁承担了最多的照料工作。同样，这是与年长、疾病等相关的研究。做得最多的孩子是地理位置上最近的孩子。第二个指标是经济上最宽裕的孩子，即有经济能力提供帮助的孩子，这意味着他们
can drive there or travel there or visit there or pay for something. So I validate for women that, particularly if you're in a family where in your childhood there were a lot of children and you were one of the older sisters it's very likely you had extra work to do and that impacted who you became in adulthood if you are part of an immigrant family and the experience of leading as a first generation American or the child who learned English and had to to help your parents with that very likely informed your experience in adulthood. The one thing that I like to separate and make distinct in the eldest daughter conversation is, are you talking about older sister stuff?
可以开车去那里，或者旅行去那里，或者探望那里，或者为某事付费。所以我向女性证实，特别是如果你在一个童年时期有很多孩子且你是大姐姐之一的家庭中，你很可能承担了额外的工作，这影响了你成年后成为了什么样的人；如果你是一个移民家庭的一部分，作为第一代美国人的领导经历，或者作为学习英语并不得不帮助父母的孩子，很可能影响了你成年后的经历。在长女的对话中，我喜欢区分并明确的一点是，你是在谈论大姐姐的事情？
Or are you talking about daughtering, which is a relationship between the adult female child and her parents? So how she relates to her parents. but often how we relate to our parents has to do with managing our siblings and being the family CEO in order to help our parent or to help the whole family. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Alford about how family dynamics change when there are no daughters in a family and whether there's a counterpart role for sons.
还是在谈论“女儿工作”，即成年女性子女与父母之间的关系？所以她如何与父母相处。但通常我们如何与父母相处与管理兄弟姐妹和成为家庭 CEO 以帮助父母或帮助整个家庭有关。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与阿尔福德博士谈谈当家庭中没有女儿时，家庭动态会发生什么变化，以及儿子是否有对应的角色。
Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply.
你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Nextgrill 四炉头燃气烧烤架来开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅来招待客人，仅需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。
See homedipo.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room.
详情请见 homedepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。
Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. What happens in families where there are no daughters? I mean, do sons take up that responsibility in those cases?
离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时，住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。当家庭中没有女儿时会发生什么？我的意思是，在这种情况下，儿子会承担那种责任吗？
Is there kind of a counterpart role for sons? And if so, what does that entail? How is it different and how is it the same? One of the kind of coolest, untapped areas of research that I would encourage anyone listening who's looking for that little gap in the literature to go for is the topic of sunning. What's what I call being a son, doing the sun things. And it's so important to say that as we're talking about the difficulties of daughtering and the expectations on women, we're not bashing sons. I have a wonderful husband who does a lot of sunning as a, you know, there's two sons in his family. And so there are no daughters. And, you know, we have talked a lot about and investigated a lot. What is what does he do? What do I do as the daughter-in-law to help with his parents? and who's responsible for that.
儿子是否有某种对应的角色？如果是这样，那包含什么？它有何不同，又有何相同之处？这是我鼓励任何正在寻找文献中那个小空白的听众去研究的最酷、未被开发的领域之一，那就是“儿子工作”（sunning）的话题。这就是我所说的身为儿子，做儿子该做的事。非常重要的一点是，当我们谈论“女儿工作”的困难和对女性的期望时，我们并不是在抨击儿子。我有一个很棒的丈夫，他作为儿子做了很多“儿子工作”，你知道，他家里有两个儿子。所以没有女儿。而且，你知道，我们已经谈论了很多，也调查了很多。他做了什么？作为儿媳，我做了什么来帮助他的父母？谁对此负责？
The main difference that I see between daughtering and sunning at the top, just, you know, at the surface level, is that sons are not expected by society or by their parents to do the social support provision type care, especially in their 20s, 30s, 40s. They're not expected to call up their parent and say, how is your week at work? And should we plan a gathering? I feel like we need to have a barbecue. You know, sons are not expected to do that or to have an inclination toward that. Are there sons who do it? Yes. There are many wonderful sons.
我看到的“女儿工作”和“儿子工作”在表面层面的主要区别在于，社会或父母并不期望儿子去做社会支持提供类型的照料，特别是在他们 20 多岁、30 多岁、40 多岁时。他们不被期望打电话给父母说，你这周工作怎么样？我们应该计划一次聚会吗？我觉得我们需要举办一次烧烤。你知道，儿子不被期望这样做，或者倾向于这样做。有这样做的儿子吗？是的。有很多很棒的儿子。
But often when a man does something loving, nurturing, connecting in his family, the whole family goes, oh, look at him. is so good at that. So then there's these kudos on top of it. And women just don't get that. We have the expectation that we're supposed to do it or even if her parent isn't expecting us to. We feel like our society is or we see someone from our friend group doing something and we feel a guilt that no one ask us to feel. And men don't typically have that. They just, when they decide to provide care, They get a lot of kudos for it. But many men are very caring, loving.
但通常当一个男人在家庭中做了一些充满爱、滋养、连接的事情时，整个家庭会说，哦，看他。他太擅长那个了。所以这之上还有赞美。而女性根本得不到这些。我们有期望，认为我们应该这样做，即使她的父母没有期望我们这样做。我们觉得我们的社会在期望，或者我们看到朋友群体中的某个人在做某事，我们感到一种没有人要求我们感受的内疚。而男人通常没有那种感觉。他们只是，当他们决定提供照料时，他们会因此得到很多赞美。但许多男人是非常有爱心、充满关怀的。
And I think this area of sunning and who decides, how men decide to show up for care provisions and connecting an emotional labor in their families is a rich, ripe area for inquiry that I don't know as much about, but would like to know more about, especially as I have a son who is 17 and we'll be heading into sunning territory of adulthood soon. What about shifting gender roles? I mean, do you know, have you looked at that much to see whether there is an effect? I mean, maybe men are expected to do more of these sort of feminine types of actions. You know, as we see change across generations, there's absolutely changes that are coming. That's more of the work of a sociologist, and so it's not in my wheelhouse, but I can say anecdotally that we see massive changes in the sharing of social
我认为这个“儿子工作”的领域，以及男人如何决定在家庭中提供照料和连接以及情感劳动，是一个丰富、成熟的探究领域，我了解得不多，但想了解更多，特别是作为一个 17 岁儿子的母亲，他很快就会进入成年后的“儿子工作”领域。关于性别角色的转变呢？我的意思是，你知道，你是否对此研究了很多，看看是否有影响？我的意思是，也许男人被期望做更多这种女性化的行为。你知道，随着我们看到几代人的变化，绝对会有变化。那是社会学家的工作，所以不在我的专业范围内，但我可以凭经验说，我们看到几代人之间在分享社会
reproductive labor between men and women through generations from baby boomer to gen X to millennial and moving on to Gen Z. We are agreeing generationally, especially millennials and Gen Z that maybe it's not worthwhile to partner with someone unless they intend to share that labor. Well, that would extend into sharing the labor of doing family, I think anecdotally we can absolutely see those expectations changing. One of the books that I like that's a current book that's out about having conversations with your partner on who does what and how do we do things is called Fair Play by Eve Rodski. And if it's something you haven't talked to your partner about, then this gives you a toolkit to do that. What I would love is,
再生产劳动方面发生了巨大的变化，从婴儿潮一代到 X 世代，再到千禧一代，并向 Z 世代发展。我们正在达成代际共识，特别是千禧一代和 Z 世代，认为除非对方打算分担这种劳动，否则与某人建立伴侣关系可能不值得。嗯，我认为这会延伸到分担家庭劳动，凭经验我们绝对可以看到这些期望正在改变。我喜欢的一本关于与伴侣讨论谁做什么以及我们如何做事的当前书籍是伊芙·罗德斯基（Eve Rodsky）的《公平竞争》（Fair Play）。如果你还没有和你的伴侣谈过这件事，那么这本书为你提供了一个工具包。我想要的是，
is to add some cards to the card deck that Eve has. And those cards are parents, in-laws, big extended family gatherings so that we notice that the work of being a family is not just our little core unit that live all in the same dwelling together, but it's also our larger family and our community, or what Ari Ho-Shild would call the third shift labor, which is what we have to do after we take care of our day job and then we take care of our little family that we live with. We still have a responsibility, particularly as women, we feel that,
在伊芙的卡片组中增加一些卡片。这些卡片是父母、姻亲、大型大家庭聚会，这样我们就会注意到，身为家庭的工作不仅仅是我们住在一起的小核心单元，还包括我们的大家庭和我们的社区，或者阿里·霍希尔德（Arlie Hochschild）所说的“第三班劳动”，也就是我们在处理完日常工作，然后照顾我们住在一起的小家庭之后必须做的事情。我们仍然有责任，特别是作为女性，我们感受到了这一点，
but as citizens and members of a society to do things for the greater good of others. These days, a lot of women live far away from their parents. So how does physical distance affect these family dynamics? In a recent study that my research partner and I did, we asked over 300 women in one-on-one interviews how they do daughtering. And one of the things that we asked them to report on is how far away do you live from your parent? Do you live in the same house? Do you live down the street, city, state, you know, country across the world? And when we spoke to the women who live across the state or they live across the country, essentially any of the women who felt like they couldn't
但作为公民和社会的成员，为了他人的共同利益而做事。如今，许多女性住得离父母很远。那么物理距离如何影响这些家庭动态呢？在我与研究伙伴最近进行的一项研究中，我们在一对一的访谈中询问了 300 多名女性她们是如何进行“女儿工作”的。我们要求她们报告的一件事是，你住得离父母有多远？你们住在同一所房子里吗？住在街对面、城市、州、你知道，国家，还是世界另一端？当我们与住在州外或全国各地的女性交谈时，基本上任何觉得无法
get to see their parent in person, they filled in for us that they're doing the same amount of daughtering. They're just doing daughtering differently. And that's really an area that we all need to lean into, is this understanding that's particularly with technology, that doing daughtering can be sending an Instagram, you know, real or texting a meme. Many daughters who lived across the country talked very specifically about how thoughtful they were, about making sure their parent had gifts or gift boxes or plenty of phone calls, and a lot of emotional support. They also leaned in more to the identity formation and talking about who do I want to be as a daughter and how can I be that person's daughter, even when we're not near each other. One woman told me, I go to work every day
亲自见到父母的女性，她们告诉我们，她们正在进行同样多的“女儿工作”。她们只是以不同的方式进行“女儿工作”。这确实是我们都需要深入研究的一个领域，即这种理解，特别是随着技术的发展，“女儿工作”可以是发送 Instagram 动态，你知道，短视频或发表情包。许多住在全国各地的女儿非常具体地谈到了她们是多么体贴，确保父母有礼物或礼品盒，或者有充足的电话交流，以及大量的情感支持。她们也更多地投入到身份认同的形成中，谈论我想成为什么样的女儿，即使我们不在一起，我如何能成为那个人的女儿。一位女性告诉我，我每天去上班
and my mom lives across the state. I don't get to see her. But when I go to work, I know that I'm working for both of us. And then I send her part of my paycheck. And she described that as treating her mom. She wanted to treat her. She wanted to have little perks or gifts that her mom didn't expect this money. And yet she was regularly sending money. And so I think that we have to see beyond the categories, particularly that daughtering has to do with face-to-face communication and tasks and visits. And then once we do that, we can imagine daughtering in a variety of different ways. And then we start to give credit to others who do different things. And that's probably one of the biggest impacts. Not only have I seen from the early readers of the book saying,
我妈妈住在州外。我见不到她。但当我上班时，我知道我是在为我们俩工作。然后我把工资的一部分寄给她。她把这描述为款待她妈妈。她想款待她。她想给一些小福利或礼物，她妈妈并没有期望这些钱。然而她还是经常寄钱。所以我认为我们必须超越那些类别，特别是“女儿工作”必须与面对面交流、任务和探访有关的类别。一旦我们这样做了，我们就可以想象各种不同方式的“女儿工作”。然后我们开始给予那些做不同事情的人以认可。这可能是最大的影响之一。不仅我从这本书的早期读者那里看到，他们说，
oh my gosh, I noticed so much more daughtering that my sister was doing or that my you know, that I was doing that I had felt guilty because my sister lives right there. So as a personal story, when I went through this research and learned about it and I was writing the book, my own sister and I had this big conversation where we divided up what kind of daughtering we do. She lives down the street from my parents. So she can just walk down there and knock on their door. She can help take care of their dog if they go out of town for the weekend.
天哪，我注意到了我姐姐正在做的，或者我正在做的，因为我姐姐就住在那里，所以我感到内疚，我注意到了更多的“女儿工作”。作为一个个人故事，当我经历这项研究并了解它，并且正在写这本书时，我和我自己的姐姐进行了这次重要的谈话，我们分工了我们进行什么样的“女儿工作”。她住在我父母家街对面。所以她可以直接走过去敲他们的门。如果他们周末出城，她可以帮忙照顾他们的狗。
I don't, but I do the emotional phone calls. I do the asking of the big questions. I also do the pushing of the not fun questions, where I can call and I can say something unpleasant or that my parent doesn't want to hear. And then I could just click, hang up the phone. And so we agreed that we're different kinds of daughters. So we're not either one of us doing more or less daughtering. We're doing this very different kind of daughtering.
我不行，但我负责情感电话。我负责问那些大问题。我也负责推动那些不好玩的问题，我可以打电话，我可以说一些不愉快的话，或者我父母不想听的话。然后我可以点击，挂断电话。所以我们同意我们是不同类型的女儿。所以我们俩都没有做得更多或更少“女儿工作”。我们正在进行这种非常不同类型的“女儿工作”。
And it really made us so much more of a team together to work for a better family life instead of feeling competitive or lacking or resentful when we compare ourselves with our sibling. Who's older? And does that make a difference? She's older. and so maybe I have my little Napoleon complex about being the younger daughter and saying, but me, but me too, I'm doing a lot of daughtering, so I don't have eldest daughter syndrome, but I do more and better at many parts of daughtering, and my sister does more and better at many other parts of daughtering. And ultimately, having my sibling as my partner, instead of constantly
这确实让我们更像一个团队，共同努力争取更好的家庭生活，而不是当我们与兄弟姐妹比较时感到竞争、缺乏或怨恨。谁更大？这有区别吗？她更大。所以也许我因为是小女儿而有我的小拿破仑情结，说，但是我也，我也在做很多“女儿工作”，所以我没有“长女综合征”，但我做得更多，在“女儿工作”的许多部分做得更好，而我姐姐在许多其他部分做得更多、更好。最终，让我的兄弟姐妹成为我的伙伴，而不是一直
wishing they were different or doing something else or, you know, thinking, I'm the only one. I'm the only one who's doing anything. It really does not breed this sort of flourishing or enjoyment in your family if you're constantly angry at your sibling and you're constantly burdened by the daughtering. The best way to go forward that I've heard from many daughters is figuring out ways to discuss it, share it, and then when needed, limit it. Limit what you are doing because you are not responsible for your parents' soul happiness and purpose in life or that you have to provide that by being one-on-one face-to-face in person with them.
希望他们与众不同或做别的事情，或者，你知道，认为，我是唯一一个。我是唯一一个做任何事情的人。如果你一直对你的兄弟姐妹生气，并且一直被“女儿工作”所累，这真的不会滋生这种家庭的繁荣或享受。我从许多女儿那里听到的最好的前进方式是找出讨论、分享的方法，然后在需要时限制它。限制你正在做的事情，因为你不负责父母灵魂的幸福和人生目标，或者你必须通过与他们面对面来提供这些。
So just some recasting of what daughtering can be and some reimagining of what you're already doing well can be a huge shift for women to feel a lot of relief and a lot of camaraderie and solidarity in doing daughtering. And the goal is to get to that part where you like it, where you enjoy it, where you think my family and being part of a family is a benefit and I want to do the work that I need to do to be in the family because I enjoy the benefits that I get from it as well. You published the research article on daughtering during the COVID-19 pandemic. I'm wondering, what did you find? How did the pandemic change women's experience of daughtering?
所以，对“女儿工作”可以是什么进行一些重塑，对你已经做得很好的事情进行一些重新想象，可以成为女性感到巨大解脱以及在进行“女儿工作”时感到更多友情和团结的巨大转变。目标是达到你喜欢它、享受它、认为我的家庭和成为家庭的一部分是一种福利，并且我想做我需要做的工作来成为家庭的一员，因为我也享受从中获得的福利的那一部分。你在 COVID-19 大流行期间发表了关于“女儿工作”的研究文章。我想知道，你发现了什么？大流行如何改变了女性的“女儿工作”经历？
One of the interesting things that came out of that was an idea that women in different phases of life started to see ways that they were daughtering that they had not ever seen before, but the COVID pandemic brought about such a physical divide and forced so many of us to start trying new ways to connect with our parent or to take care of them or it shined a light on how hard it is to worry about your parent but have so little control. And many people learned about that feeling at a much younger age than what you might typically start to feel that as a daughter, maybe which were your 40s or 50s or something, you learned about it when you were 25 and you're thinking, I'm worried about my parents. They're not masking. They have a respiratory disease,
其中一件有趣的事情是，处于不同人生阶段的女性开始看到她们以前从未见过的进行“女儿工作”的方式，但 COVID 大流行带来了如此巨大的物理鸿沟，并迫使我们许多人开始尝试新的方式与父母联系或照顾他们，或者它照亮了担心父母却几乎无法控制是多么困难。许多人在比你通常开始作为女儿感受到这一点时更年轻的年龄就了解到了那种感觉，也许是在你 40 多岁或 50 多岁时，你在 25 岁时就了解到了，你在想，我担心我的父母。他们没有戴口罩。他们有呼吸道疾病，
but they keep going out to talk to all the neighbors. And so in that study, one of the most interesting things was just realizing that when daughtering and the facets of daughtering and the needs of our parent are made more visible to us, then we can wrap our mind around, what can I do, what can I not do, what am I willing to take under my control that I need to be doing for this parent and what do I have to let go? And so much of being a good daughter has to do with thinking, what am I doing for them, but I also have to protect me. So I have to balance the way that I use and share my resources. And in COVID-19, resources were extremely strained at work with our little families,
但他们一直出去和所有的邻居交谈。所以在那项研究中，最有趣的事情之一就是意识到，当“女儿工作”以及“女儿工作”的各个方面和父母的需求对我们变得更加可见时，我们就可以理解，我能做什么，我不能做什么，我愿意控制什么，我需要为这位父母做什么，我必须放手什么？身为好女儿的很大一部分与思考有关，我为他们做了什么，但我还必须保护我自己。所以我必须平衡我使用和分享资源的方式。在 COVID-19 中，资源在工作中、在我们的核心家庭中、
with the children that we have, with our partners, with our finances. And so everybody just became a lot more aware that these resources are finite, and I must distribute them across the people in my life who I care about very thoughtfully and very carefully. Some of what we've been talking about makes being a daughter sound like a bit of a burden or a slog. And I'm just wondering if there's an upside to taking on these roles. Or is it just the attitude that you have toward the work of a daughter that you're doing? Well, some of what can be first noticed about daughtering is how hard it is and how challenging it is. And often that's true of so many things in our life.
在我们的孩子、我们的伴侣、我们的财务方面都极其紧张。所以每个人都变得更加意识到这些资源是有限的，我必须非常深思熟虑和非常小心地将它们分配给我生活中我关心的人。我们一直在谈论的一些事情使身为女儿听起来有点像是一种负担或苦差事。我只是想知道承担这些角色是否有积极的一面？还是仅仅是你对你正在做的女儿工作所持的态度？嗯，关于“女儿工作”首先能注意到的事情之一是它有多难，有多具挑战性。通常我们生活中的许多事情都是如此。
You're married and you just notice. all the time how annoying this person is, right? Are you kids and you're thinking, this is just so hard and they're always wanting to eat every day, you know, and so that's maybe human nature that we tend to notice what is hard, but it's also our way of reaching out to people in our community and saying, are you, are you suffering too? Is this hard for you too? And so it is important to talk about the resources that are necessary to do daughtering and where are those coming from. Where am I, as a busy woman with limited resources, funds, time, energy, where am I pulling from to give to my parent? And do I have that to give?
你结婚了，你一直注意到这个人的烦人之处，对吧？或者你有孩子，你觉得，这太难了，他们每天都要吃东西，你知道，所以这也许是人性，我们倾向于注意到困难的事情，但这也是我们向社区中的人们伸出援手，说，你也在受苦吗？这对你来说也难吗？所以谈论进行“女儿工作”所需的资源以及这些资源来自哪里是很重要的。作为一个资源、资金、时间、精力有限的忙碌女性，我从哪里提取资源来给予我的父母？我有这些可以给予吗？
But I think that the most wonderful part that came out of my research is that almost every daughter that I spoke to said, yeah, it's hard, but I want to do it. Or I don't want to stop doing it. I really love my parent. My parent loves me. I enjoy being in a family. The thing about love and enjoyment and feeling identity in family is that it often taps into what the way I like to think about it is our eutomonic happiness. Eudomon is, this Martin Seligman talked about in his happiness studies, the kind of happiness that makes us feel good over a lifespan. Am I a good person?
但我认为我的研究中最精彩的部分是，我交谈过的几乎每一位女儿都说，是的，这很难，但我还是想做。或者我不想停止做它。我真的很爱我的父母。我的父母爱我。我喜欢身处一个家庭中。关于爱、享受和在家庭中感受身份认同的事情是，它通常触及我喜欢思考的方式，即我们的“幸福感”（eudaimonic happiness）。马丁·塞利格曼（Martin Seligman）在他的幸福研究中谈到了“幸福感”，这种幸福感让我们在整个生命周期中感觉良好。我是一个好人吗？
Do I like my life? Do I feel like I've contributed? when I die, I feel like I was a good person. I was a good daughter. But oftentimes the things we have to do for doing daughtering, like avoiding conflict or carrying an emotional load, they don't contribute to our hedonic happiness. Hedonic happiness is the zing of fun. Like, let's go out to the movies. Let's get some, you know, chicken nuggets and popcorn and sit there and watch this movie and, you know, and it's just this little fun time. And many women are not accessing on a regular basis hedonic happiness with their adult parents.
我喜欢我的生活吗？我觉得我做出了贡献吗？当我死时，我觉得我是一个好人。我是一个好女儿。但通常我们必须为“女儿工作”做的事情，比如避免冲突或承担情感负担，它们对我们的“享乐幸福”（hedonic happiness）没有贡献。“享乐幸福”是乐趣的刺激。比如，让我们去看电影。让我们买些鸡块和爆米花，坐在那里看这部电影，你知道，这只是这种小小的快乐时光。许多女性并没有经常与她们的成年父母一起获得“享乐幸福”。
And so they're still happy, but in a eutemonic sense of I'm a good daughter. And so what I have seen is that if we start talking about the daughtering we're doing, what we want to be doing, what we don't want to be doing, what we want from our family, what we don't want from our family and we adjust it, we share it, then we can start to find more of those moments of hedonic happiness and that we can note them to ourselves and say out loud, I enjoyed that. So for me, when I go visit my parents at the holiday, I have made a boundary that I spend two nights because any more than two nights and we start losing hedonic happiness and getting into arguments and frustration.
所以她们仍然很快乐，但在“幸福感”的意义上，我是个好女儿。所以我看到的是，如果我们开始谈论我们正在做的“女儿工作”，我们想做什么，我们不想做什么，我们想要从家人那里得到什么，我们不想要从家人那里得到什么，然后我们调整它，分享它，那么我们就可以开始找到更多那些“享乐幸福”的时刻，我们可以对自己记录下来，并大声说出来，我享受那个。所以对我来说，当我节假日去探望父母时，我设定了一个界限，我待两晚，因为超过两晚，我们就会开始失去“享乐幸福”，陷入争论和挫折。
And of course, I'm sleeping in a different bed and eating different food. And so I made a boundary for myself, but I feel good that I go. I feel good that I show up. I want to show up. And I have started this ritual on the way home that I talked to my husband about what I liked about the stay there. So it's a balance of going and doing the things, putting some boundaries in on the places where you realize this is not no longer neutral or fun. There's no hedonic happiness coming, so I've got to get out of here.
当然，我睡在不同的床上，吃着不同的食物。所以我为自己设定了界限，但我很高兴自己去了。我很高兴自己能出席。我想出席。在回家的路上，我开始了一个仪式，就是和丈夫谈论我在那里住得开心的地方。所以，这是一种平衡，既要去参与，也要在意识到某些地方不再中立或有趣时设定界限。既然已经没有快乐可言，我就得离开这里。
But then when you leave, you don't ruminate and narrate all the bad things or the most annoying things. You have to narrate what you liked. And many women, we need to have those moments where we narrate what we like. I like that my dad texts me these weather updates when he thinks I'll be driving in the rain. I like that my mom always remembers to buy me this special perfume for my birthday. What do we like about living in a family and make sure that we're narrating that out loud so that we don't forget that the whole point of this daughtering is we're doing it because we love these people and we do like being in families with them. So what's next for you in this area? I mean, you've published the book.
但当你离开时，不要反复咀嚼和讲述那些糟糕或最令人恼火的事情。你必须讲述你喜欢的事情。我们许多女性需要那些讲述我们所爱之事的时刻。我喜欢我爸爸在觉得我会开车遇到雨天时给我发天气预报。我喜欢我妈妈总是记得在生日时给我买这种特别的香水。我们喜欢家庭生活的什么？我们要确保大声说出来，这样我们就不会忘记，尽女儿责任的全部意义在于我们这样做是因为我们爱这些人，而且我们确实喜欢和他们生活在一起。那么，在这个领域你接下来有什么计划？我的意思是，你已经出版了这本书。
Is there more research that you're doing into daughtering? Absolutely. So we have that big research project that we completed across 24, 25, and we have multiple research articles coming out about that this year, several accepted, several in progress. We're interested in continuing studies where we can take, you know, everything is just a cross-sectional view, but we can maybe take more of a lifespan view across the populations. We've loved our study, most of our studies have been with American women. So we would love to branch out internationally and look at different populations and different cultures. For me,
你还在进行关于女儿角色的研究吗？当然。我们在24、25年完成了那个大型研究项目，今年会有多篇研究文章发表，几篇已被接受，几篇正在进行中。我们有兴趣继续进行研究，我们可以采取，你知道，目前一切都只是横截面视图，但我们也许可以对不同人群进行更长生命周期的观察。我们很喜欢我们的研究，我们的大多数研究都是针对美国女性的。所以我们很乐意向国际扩展，观察不同的人群和不同的文化。对我个人而言，
personally, I am really excited to bring this material from the academic kind of shadows where are some things, they can reach a few of us, but not as many people as this material could help. And what I really want to see is the topic of daughtering, the work of improving our lives and enjoying our families in the hands of as many regular everyday women who might never read a research article as possible. Well, Dr. Alfred, I want to thank you for joining me today. And thanks for shining a light on this area of human existence. I really appreciate the time to talk about this.
我非常兴奋能将这些材料从学术的阴影中带出来，在那里，有些东西只能触及我们少数人，而无法触及更多能从这些材料中受益的人。我真正想看到的是，关于女儿角色的主题，关于改善我们的生活和享受家庭的工作，能交到尽可能多的普通女性手中，她们可能永远不会去读研究文章。好的，阿尔弗雷德博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。感谢你照亮了人类存在的这一领域。我非常感谢能有时间谈论这个话题。
I appreciate your listeners for considering it and thinking, hey, that sounds like a real thing, because that is what moves the research forward. And I always want to say thank you to reviewer one and reviewer two, right, for helping this work get out there. All right. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology
我很感谢你的听众能考虑并思考，嘿，这听起来确实是一回事，因为这正是推动研究前进的动力。我总是想对审稿人一和审稿人二说声谢谢，感谢他们帮助这项工作得以发表。好了，你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的剧集有评论或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology
at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop.
at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的基姆·米尔斯。在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价商品。下载 Ralph's 应用程序，每周还可以通过数字优惠券获得更多优惠。此外，您还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最多可节省 1 美元。在 Ralph's，您每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。
So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. Seasite for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，通过储蓄和奖励，每天都能轻松省大钱。Ralph's SoCal 150 多年来一直如此。储蓄可能因州而异。燃油限制适用。详情请见网站。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。